et je veux d'abord dire
la douleur qui est la mienne ils sont
celle que tous les parisiens
dire aux familles des victimes
c'est donc
nous sommes à leurs côtés et partageons
ce moment d'horreur ce moment
terrifiant pour notre ville ne sommes
pas très loin
lieux des attentats et notamment de
charlie hebdo
moins d'un an aujourd'hui et je veux
aussi saluer et remercier le travail
incroyable
et policiers des policiers de la berri
durel qui sont intervenus ce soir et qui
malgré
nombre de victimes
absolument considérables ont réussi à
sauver beaucoup de vies
donc je veux vraiment leur dire merci
merci à toutes ces forces de l'ordre au
secours qui ont été là et qui ont pu
prendre en charge
beaucoup de victimes blessées et
j'espère pouvoir bien sûr les soleils ce
soir c'est le moment
de la douleur les pleurs du deuil mais
paris est là debout et je sais que les
parisiens qui vont souffrir avec ceux
qui sont enlevés ce soir nous saurons
aussi se relever pour être d'abord aux
côtés des victimes
et puis pour montrer que cette liberté
cette liberté qu'il ya dans notre ville
cette joie dit qu'il y a dans notre
ville il ne l'atteint dans le temps
l'amygdale brusque